it's been protected from human impact
since 1909 with three million acres
nearly a half-million underwater
Superior National Forest is largely
unspoiled but now the survival of this
national treasure rests with those who'd
see some of it burn when a massive
windstorm flattened nearly a half
million acres of trees in July of 1999
the Forest Service knew a major wildfire
was inevitable they refer to this area
simply as the blowdown over 700 square
miles of kindling just waiting for spark
yeah we're kind of wondering why that
hasn't happened on when it's twice as
dry trace is warm and windy and and
there's lightning out there but so far
we just haven't had lightning in a good
patch of timber to burn on this day this
to let you know the magnetic rock burn
is a goal the Forest Service will strike
the match weather forecast for today is
favorable but not before checking that
conditions are just right pretty
consistent mainly southwesterly 10 to 15
gusts of wind more than 15 miles per
hour in the wrong direction could be
disastrous and if things go wrong if the
fire gets out of control it will be
burned boss Tim Norman who's responsible
it will come from above the helicopter
disappearing over this Ridge will drop a
flaming gel on the forest floor the
natural fuel there does the rest for
hours wave after wave of air assaults
rain fire from above this is the time
when all that planning to keep
homeowners safe is put to the test
before the burn during the burning after
the burn we're trying to look at as many
angles as we can to try and outguess
what could possibly happen and conduct
this safely in the end a plan with
promise gave way to some disappointment
no safety problems but the Forest
Service had hoped to burn 1300 acres
shifting winds and problems with the
flaming gel limited the burn to just 200
but that is still a significant amount
of forest to burn how long will this
area take the green up Oh it'll be green
by next spring this area now creates a
much needed buffer between the blowdown
and hundreds of homes and businesses on
the edge of the wilderness burning the
forest to keep a future wildfire in
check it's a huge job that's only just
begun